when you make a formal declaration of
war the last thing you expect is for it
to be rejected but this is what happened
to poland during world war ii when its
government in exile declared war in
japan the japanese refused to accept
this declaration as valid and thus
promptly ignored it which raises a
pretty obvious question why why did
japan refuse to acknowledge that poland
was at war with it so during the
interwar period japan and poland had
very good relations this was due to
their mutual dislike of the soviet union
and the two nations cooperated deeply in
conducting espionage within the ussr
japanese listening stations were located
within poland and polish spies were
smuggled in and out of the ussr by the
vast japanese puppet state of manchukuo
however as you'll know the japanese
allied with the germans during the
second world war and its ally conquered
poland the japanese deeply disapproved
of this in part because their close ally
had just been wiped out but also because
germany had done this in tandem with the
ussr which the japanese government
viewed as his greatest threat that said
there wasn't anything that it could do
about the destruction of poland and so
the japanese simply said nothing at
least publicly privately japan supported
the polish government in london and the
two continued to spy on the ussr
together of course at this point japan
wasn't at war with the western powers
but when this changed in 1941 the polish
government in exile declared war on
japan like their hosts so the japanese
response was simple no we're not
actually at war its main justification
was that the polish government in exile
wasn't free to do as it chose and was at
this point a client of the british
acting under immense pressure from the
americans thus as far as the japanese
were concerned the polish didn't really
want to declare war on their old allies
and friends don't let friends declare
war on friends against their will of
course the japanese also viewed
countries like australia new zealand
india and canada in the same light but
they accepted their declarations of war
and the reason for that was proximity
poland was half a world away and unable
to actually do anything whereas the
others could project forces near enough
to japan to cause a potential issue also
they sat where japan wanted to expand
her empire another issue was that whilst
they wished to continue working with the
polish in order to spy on the ussr they
didn't want to upset their german allies
too much and acknowledging the
declaration of war would also be
acknowledging that a poland still
existed so after the ignored declaration
of war what happened well nothing the
polish couldn't do anything against
japan because they had much more
pressing issues closer to home and when
japan surrendered to the allies poland
wasn't at the ceremony this was because
during negotiations with the ussr the
western allies had agreed to stop
recognizing the polish government in
exile as legitimate and so after this
when normal relations were restored
between japan and the allies in 1951
poland's representative was the head of
the polish people's republic a communist
state which japan was not a fan of and
the two held no formal relations until
1957. this was when japan acknowledged
communist rule there as legitimate and
also sort of maybe made peace despite
not really ever having been to war just
to sort of get things over with i hope
you enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to my patrons james bisonette
kelly money maker skye chappelle corso
wolff jerry lamdon jordan longley adam
stalter marcus arsenault wyan hockey
spencer lightfoot rod d martin words
about books podcast captain cydog gustav
swann marvin cassell common yoon winston
k wood boogie wiggly daniel to be in
miss izzette aaron the white corey
turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski schwennin spinning three
plates and charles the first